foreign
not South but North Little Rock what's
up Abigail
hey hey
um you're breaking up try that one again
what about now much better much better
how we doing
I'm doing good I do have to say I was at
the Taylor Swift concert on Sunday here
in Nashville
yes it was the best and the worst
why was it why was it the worst we all
know why it was the best but why was it
the worst because of the lightning and
the rain we were stuck in the stadium
for four hours
whoa did they cancel this I mean did
they stop the show enlightening they did
she played from 10 P.M to 1 30 A.M
dude that's dedication right there can
we just okay
stay the night in Nashville you have to
drive all the way back to Arkansas
no he stayed and we left
um early the next morning we were
running on three hours of sleep hey some
things are worth it like the birth of a
child the death of a parent and Taylor
Swift amen
oh you just made Jenna's whole day
there's a whole oh my gosh y'all are wow
okay so what's up how can I help
all right so my question is how do you
know in a relationship if you're just
too different to make it work
tell me more
okay so I have noticed that I have a
habit of dating people that are
struggling with emotional regulation and
occasionally addiction and my job is
also a therapist
awesome and so I tend to see the best in
people and always see people for their
per like for their potential and so I
just can't tell when in a relationship
I'm staying and I'm being supportive of
someone in a rough season or when maybe
they need time to grow and mature on
their own
I don't know I'm kind of struggling with
that Dynamic of like when to walk away
when you know that someone's ready for a
relationship I guess
okay so two questions one when you say I
always see the best in people that is
often code for
I need them to be this certain way in my
fantasy world because I can't live in a
world where people are x y and z
is that fair or is that not like you can
say do this that's not true at all
I mean possibly I feel like
um
I'm a pretty open-minded and
understanding person but I keep on I
don't know how but I keep on dating
people with anger issues and I think
that's one of my biggest triggers as
well in a relationship who had anger
issues in your life growing up
um
maybe my mom my dad was the opposite of
that to where he was very passive and
not very emotionally available but he
was there doing things like the physical
aspects like paying the bills and
changing the oils in my car
um he was like the fun person to hang
out with but my mom I would say was
mostly the one that was in charge and
was always kind of having to be the bad
cop too so when you say he was fun to
hang around with but he was not
emotionally available pull that apart
for me
we would be able to spend quality time
together like watching movies or going
on like a week-long trip around the
United States
um but whenever it would come to any
type of deeper conversation he would
just kind of feel awkward and shut down
and not really know what to say so
anything kind of emotion related that's
something that I would always go to my
mom for gotcha so
I have found over and over and over
again
non-scientifically I haven't found any
studies that support this but it just is
one of those things that keeps showing
up as a truth
um that we marry our unfinished business
um we either
you're trying to solve mom's anger like
why was she so mad with me and your body
continually finds people that you are
going to be in a relationship with that
have that same pulsing nuclear reactor
core in their chest and you set off to
try to solve it and you are do that
through thinking the best of people or
wishing the best about people or
fantasizing their their they could be
this one day or your body's trying to
connect with somebody in some meaningful
way and often people who are angry a lot
are emotional a lot and people who are
emotional a lot can also be incredibly
loving when that machine is turned off
either way your body's trying to solve a
problem that it has been trying to solve
for a long long time and that's why you
find yourself in this dating Loop this
this pattern over and over and over
again if the people look different they
have different jobs but at the core
they're still struggling with the same
thing that sets your body's alarms off
right
um I
give me an example there's a reason you
called why did you call did something
happen recently
Taylor Swift if so get rid of it no
absolutely not he would not be accepted
all right so what is it
um so I have been married before
um I've been divorced coming up on a
year and whenever I'm married I think
looking back I married him based on the
potential of what he could be so he
struggled with anger issues and
struggled with addiction and he said
that he wanted to change and wanted to
get help
um and then whenever we started living
together after we got married I feel
like a lot of things came out of the
woodwork and I sat down and I said you
know I need this from you to feel safe I
don't feel emotionally safe
um he was Gaslight and then do you love
bombing afterwards and he there was
never any physical abuse but he would
like throw things down and slam doors
and yell
um and so after asking him to get help
for so long he would always be
remorseful and say that he wanted to
change but he never really did that and
so I started coming home to my own home
that we shared not feeling safe and so
after feeling that way for a year
I eventually ended things because I just
I couldn't keep going and do you hear
how do you hear how what you just
described is almost a blend of your mom
and dad
yes my brother also struggled with
addiction so we can throw that in there
too well it just sounds like however you
have chosen to remember it
um again it's not fair for me in in five
minutes just to just throw shade but
what we know about our childhood
memories is they often are way incorrect
on either side of a barbell I had the
best childhood ever except I just
um struggle with distorted eating and
this and this and this and this and it's
like ah well maybe or I had the worst
childhood ever and when you peel it back
it's like it actually wasn't the word
right so it's often a barbell of one or
the other
man it sounds like y'all grew up in a
home that had some emotional absence in
it and that your bodies are whether it's
looking for drugs or looking for love in
all the wrong places it is you have
bodies that are searching for Connection
in almost desperate ways
[Music]
[Applause]
into another relationship almost
immediately of course she did because
relationships are your drug it's your
drugs yes
foreign
was it very similar to the one you just
hopped out of
to where they got upset at an ATM
machine because it ate their cards and
so they kicked the ATM machine and then
they started cussing at it and then like
hitting it and this has never happened
before but I feel like my whole body
went into a fatal flight as my heart
started speeding up and I started
shaking and when they came back to the
car I almost felt like unsafe to be in
the car with them like everything in my
body was just telling me to run yeah
because you were in the presence of a
grown-up child
children hit inanimate objects
in cursed inanimate objects children
it's something that I struggle with
though is I'm like okay but behind that
person that's struggling with anger like
there's a lot of pain and do I need to
stay in a relationship and just be
patient while they figure that out but
also that's something that I found out
is super triggering for me so I guess I
just don't know where to find the
balance of everyone has their struggles
and everyone is in a state of growth
like I know that this person is trying
to grow and try to be better but when do
you know to walk away I I don't know it
number one you're doing a good job of
trusting your body it'll let you know
that you're not safe number two you
can't
um you can't fix everybody
I know over time and that's a pathology
for you that is that is your a childhood
wound that you've been carrying around
that I'll just let's just use dad as an
example that you're still asking
yourself as an adult
what was it about me that was so
unlovable that Dad wouldn't plug into
or you're asking yourself what was it
about me that made mom that mad that she
smashed the cabinets until one of the
drawers came out
and you're continuing to ask that and
ask that an asset and your body is
desperate for connection
and it can get connection through
proxies like alcohol like opiates like
um weed doesn't really provide it but it
shuts down the alarm system
um or hop it into relationship after
relationship after relationship
it's the same drug it's just I mean it's
different drugs but it's the same issue
right for me the how do I know we're
going to grow we're growing together
that it's worth sticking it out is when
somebody invites me into
they're hurt they're pain
that's when I know I ca I can't keep
Schwan diving or cannonballing into
other people's lives thinking I'm gonna
fix them they didn't invite me in
and the hardest part for someone like
you who loves and cares about other
people you've dedicated your whole life
to it is being romantically involved
with somebody who has not invited you in
and you're looking through the window of
their soul being like I can see it right
there where it hurts and I even went to
grad school I know how to help and they
don't want your help they just want to
yell and kick and scream there will come
a season in their life when either they
have to deal with it or not but they
haven't invited you in
and that sucks that hurts these people
that I've dated do invite me in
okay I feel like they're in a state to
where they invite me in and they always
say that they're sorry and try to make
up for it and I can see behavior is a
language I'm trying to grow behavior is
a language you knew I was going to say
that behavior is a language
and listen uh
when you're in a relationship with
somebody personal development which is a
phrase that just gives me hemorrhoids
but personal development is something we
do together
for our relationship this world we're
building together
and that's super unpopular and it's
super not Bro Science whatever dude like
I gotta Smash It and Crush no dude
my personal development if I do it all
by myself and my wife does her personal
development all by herself we're gonna
end up 2 000 miles away from each other
so in the morning when I'm up at this
morning I was up at 4 48 in the morning
work and I went to the gym and then I
went on the front porch and did my
assignment that my counselor gave me
that's all personal development but it's
all working towards the goal of me being
a better husband and me being a more
peaceful grown man and me being a better
dad
so it's working in service of not just
working in service of a six-pack or
um cooler muscles or getting my job
promotion see what I'm saying
yeah and when you are working in on you
and you are in he is working on him and
y'all are working on each other I mean
you're working on yourselves towards a
common goal towards a common mission
there's just an innate hey man can you
look at this challenge differently than
me can you see another picture and
that's an invitation in when somebody
sits down with you and it's like oh
you're a counselor you can help me not
be depressed that's not an invitation in
when somebody says oh my gosh I love how
good of a listener you are let me tell
you about all my Pro they're just you
you're being used as a tool to prop them
up
so maybe even feels like an invitation I
think
and you're not gonna like this but I
think you need a detox
I think you need a season of being alone
hanging out with girlfriends
having fun adventures and getting to
know who the heck Abigail is
what does Abigail need what does Abigail
want with her one precious Reckless life
what does she want with all
and I think when you start answering
those questions then you will meet
somebody and your heart will beat a
little bit faster and his will too
and y'all will begin the process of
creating something awesome together not
just co-competing I can fix you I don't
I can crush it I can help fix you I can
dominate it that's just not a recipe for
love that's a recipe for ongoing just
continuing the
only Trauma from one system to another
thank you so much for the call Abigail I
I think you need some peace
who peace
and from there a new relationship will
will grow I'm confident of that
you're two you're too wonderful of a
person